hey everyone this is Jason Schroeder the
game director for South Park the
fractured but whole and with me today is
hi I'm Kimberly Wiegand the Associate
Producer on South Park the fractured
butthole
alright so it's our first night here as
a superhero in South Park and we're the
sidekick of this guy right here
this is Captain diabetes captain
diabetes that's right his name is also
Scott malkinson and he is a kid with
diabetes all right so we've just broken
into this window and we're going to be
looking for some sort of girl this guy
says so the girl he's referring to is
someone who knows something about
missing cats in town our mission tonight
our mission tonight is to get
information because we want the reward
for finding these missing cats yes it's
a very fun kids playing superhero as
type of thing that the kids are doing in
South Park that's great all right so uh
oh and sorry before you move on I do
want to mention this guy is great so I
have to mention that pretty much every
character in this game has been hand
animated so everything you see here is
just painstakingly was animated by a
real person all the regular unique so
this guy is actually one of our
favorites that he is fun and he's kind
of like extra all of that work all right
so let's head out to the main hippo
floor and see if we can find our girl
[Music]
okay
Wow the ladies are really moving well
don't freak out like it we're
superheroes
we can handle it one of these ladies has
information about the missing pack but
who there's only one thing we can do we
have to pick someone and take him to the
VIP room find someone and maybe they're
all right Luke is totally unfazed all
right so as Scott says we need someone
to take us to VIP and our mission just
told us to talk to some strippers so I'm
gonna talk to this young lady and she
immediately insults me and tells me
daycare is behind the bar I feel like
I'm not being taken seriously was this
guy saying talk right now guys too busy
dropping the jam this guy is great so
he's the peppermint hippo DJ and we at
the studio loved him like we parody him
all the time he definitely is a dev
favorite and he's busy dropping these
jams what do you think I am a serious
crime fighter lady
come back when you're 21 and I'll let
you suck online instead she's taking me
more seriously so we've talked to all
three strippers now great and oh there's
Ned Nimmo even couraging all right again
painstakingly hand-animated every
characters game
fantastic all right Scots ready up VIP
let's see if he's felt had any more like
hey you two girls ready to party
so this is your friend huh hotties [ __ ]
all right would you like to get her to
be happy I think these guys are a little
too drunk
oh no it's kind of sure they clearly
think you're grown up we'll take the one
with a speech impediment come on get
some dances let's go in there and talk
for a little lap yeah first we get
chances then we talked oh okay
oh no no have you gentlemen ever had
dances from a girl with a penis tattoo
hey we didn't come back here to talk
baby
yeah no talking until you finish
grinding on our jugs
oh okay you know what just me okay
so what this means Scott is that you and
I are ready to do anything for our
superhero franchise it also means that
these guys are confused and drunk and
they think that we're grown women and
because I'm Scott Scott's sidekick I
think I just kind of need to go along
with it so I'm gonna follow what it says
to do on screen here and start moving in
a clockwise direction ooh
oh nice so now I got some kind of new
control wonder what that does
yeah oh it finds of course the new kids
powers are all of our face so he of
course is letting it loose starting on
this poor guy well I mean this is a good
way to get information at them we're not
we're not here to entertain we're here
to get information on skipper the penis
that you sticking up in the IT room all
right what kind of move is that we've
seen it up this is not new timing right
it says we're moving the analog stick up
on hands when you're timing the parts
with the other right I'm moving one two
one these sweet dance moves and then
trying to tank requires protection the
best way to torture yeah I don't think
he's actually enjoying this
[Music]
I don't think he's given in yet
no no more parts are needed
that's Hara ready to talk almost here we
go this is it my finisher
nice that's right
gonna talk wow I feel like we've all
learned something fan chat time oh man
so what kind of work are you guys you
and if you ever danced with a girl here
who has a penis tattoo why are you keep
talking about a stripper with a penis
tattoo yeah yeah classy that's her day
okay
classy interrogation guys ready to total
dick that hangs off the sea which [ __ ]
the L out of the a SS of course hence
the catchy classy okay what are you
talking about this the worst VIP
experience ever yeah I did was get
farted on you ain't going nowhere haha I
am no ordinary stripper I am captain
diabetes what nice high kick and I
simply use our powers of disguise to
extract information from you you won't
get away with this
captain diabetes okay well we have the
information we need now it's classy
mm-hmm just like in the recent seasons
of South Park so now we're gonna go find
our girl but first we have to fight our
way past these guys and just like a lot
of the adults in South Park these guys
you know one moment we're doing very
adult things and the next minute hey
they're now ready to play a kids game
they just switch gears and switch
personas and say you won't get away with
this captain diabetes and now they're
just gonna play by our combat rules
exactly all right so let's jump into the
fight
[Music]
Denine yes alright so in the bottom
right corner of the screen you'll see
our time line which means that it this
is the new kids turn first and he's
going to be followed by a couple of
these enemies so on the other side you
see that my powers over here are I got
Faraday uncaged and a venous dirt trap
and a snowball flurry so I'm gonna start
with an opening venous dirt trap and see
what that does
alright an elemental dirt attack that's
a great opening hit oh man
clearly he is an angry frustrated man
yeah they do a lot of damage they are
wasted and they're just doing big hits
all over the place alright so Scott is a
little bit different than what the main
characters carrying he's got coma combo
sugar rush and insulin shock all of his
amazing diabetes themed attacks he's
sort of a tank character he does a lot
of damage as you'll see here
all right we broke that table okay she
is also a favorite on the dev team one
of the best strippers we have a lot of
funny animating her to everybody give it
up for blaze alright so let's see what
else we got I'm going to try keep taking
out this guy with Faraday uncaged okay
that applies shucks and knocks him back
for friends 30% off sub if we got 7 oh
cool so what just happened there with
that shock damage that I pledged went
off at the end of his turn and it was
enough to knock him out okay so now
Scott and I are gonna move in for the
kill on this guy we're gonna get
surrounded
does he look kind of nervous that is a
but he was taken out of combat that's
great
alright I'm going to let's see I'm gonna
apply this new snowball flurry which is
another elementalist attack high price
$20 tripper
gosh these guys know a lot okay because
he's chilled he actually had to skip his
turn and now Scott's gonna get to move
in we're gonna use his coma combo head
and knock him into the new kid let's see
all right and we could get one more
counter-attack
let's send them back the other direction
one more faraday on Cade go Scott yeah
take him down all right
I was exciting so now we got some XP
from that fight which is heading and
getting us closer to a new hero rank and
down here we also got some components
but let's talk about what those do in
the next video we'll be covering some
exploration in crafting thanks for
watching and stay tuned for part two
Sapa the fractured but home is available
October 17th get the stick of truth free
with purchase pre-order now for tally
bonus content don't forget to bring it
down
you